who is more trustworthy to keep a family
secret oh Jason is a blabbermouth who is
harder to wake up in the morning for
school we'd have to go in there
sometimes threatening with throwing
water on him and I found out later he
was up late texting people at night who
is more likely to cook a better family
dinner neither one of them cook who was
more likely to ruin a family picture
Travis was always the one doing
something silly he would do something
weird with his mouth he would put his
hands up here and you know do one of
those who was the better liar and who
was the worst liar Travis is a better
liar Jason does not lie he has no filter
and he's made me cry I remember Jason
one time I had used the wrong hair color
on my hair and it was like a fieria red
like almost as bright as this jacket and
he said Mom I want two Big Macs and an
order of fries he thought I would just
like Ronald McDonald